Let's go next to our caller from the five
one six area code.
Who is calling today from five one six.
Hello, this is Devin.
So I just have one question.
Yes, yes.
Uh, do you think that opening an investigation
into McConnell and other likely or obviously
complicit Senate Republicans might give us
a chance that a conviction in the Senate,
you know, put them on hot coals, you know,
no, probably not.
They'd stone wallet, they'd play the martyr
victim game and Fox news would help them do
it.
So now I unfortunately, even if it would be
the right thing to do to investigate them,
I don't believe that we would really get much
out of it.
Unfortunately, it's, it's, I hate to be that
cynical, but it's the way I see it.
Hmm.
Cause I was thinking about, you know, how
we're possibly going to be investigating new
nests in the house, but, right.
Alright.
Thank you.
All right, thank you very much.
Appreciate the phone call.